so these little operations are
dramatically changed by these robots to
you it's amazing to watch when these
things sort of disappear in there and
reappear when they're ready with an
order what do you see when you see the
robots how is this changing operation
most what we've been doing fulfillment
for 20 years and improving every year
this is a step function improvement to
our last type of building you think
about the challenge we face it's all
about this massive selection we carry
this sight we're in today has over three
and a half million units of unique
selection over twenty one and a half
million it's a total inventory and
walking that selection defined product
for the exact thing the customer wanted
the shipment used to take a lot of time
there were 21 million items here there
are 21 million over over three million
types of it exactly and it is really
it's really bewildering to watch like
children's toys and power drills and and
I don't know you name it everything you
know everything from toys the vitamins
to you know toy rockets your eyes my
family and I have two sons we probably
do 90% of our shopping the names on
between fresh and where you can buy
boxes are going to my house right now
actually I look closer but let me ask
the question you know does the stowing
and picking method is it as effective in
with the robots does that change the way
it works it fundamentally changes it
because it eliminates the wall what you
see now is everything we're doing is
just the value-added element to the
customer it's putting the product in
available for sale this stuff is
available right now for same-day
delivery into San Francisco order it by
new and get it tonight and the same
thing on the pick side when the product
is delivered to the picker it's just
immediately there they're available to
go it's on the way out so where we were
previously processing orders in an hour
to an hour and a half
whereas fastest cycle times are now down
to as little as under 15 minutes it's
amazing so you also you've been at this
about six months I've got imagine
there's a tremendous amount of learning
that you guys are going through with us
and trying to figure out oh you know
that's gonna actually help us with what
like what areas are you learning
it'sjust there's three big pieces here
with this system one is capacity
expansion it's all about getting more
product more selection available locally
for customers into the same footprint so
in this building right now we're getting
50% more product per square foot of
space than we were in our previous
generation of the function of the the
catacombs essentially don't have to be
reachable it's not like a library
exactly
so because of the T the system doesn't
need pic I'll sort walkways for people
and you don't need the intermediate
material handling systems get a lot more
density of storage as you can see back
there there's very few open access
higher as well that you can't suppose
your Pickers are six foot five although
well we have anything doesn't work on a
bagel I assume well you're always
welcome so talk about the location of
this facility it's very interesting to
me that it's you know an hour or two
from San Francisco from San Jose from
Sacramento how do you cite the locations
and how is it the change in amazon's
sort of tax policy aidid that well they
we're all about getting closer to
customers and so as I said the first
benefit here is all about getting more
selections both to the customers then
it's about speed of processing that you
get with pita and our ability to facet
astir process for delivery to those
customers as we scale the network as you
move from one building to many buildings
you're able to get much closer to
customers so when you have five
buildings like we did back in 1999 you
are more of a regional fulfillment
player we now have 50 buildings in the
US 109 globally and with that footprint
we're able to now be much closer at two
the urban locations where customers are
located the impact of sandy liver and
Sunday delivery I was I was shocked a
few weeks ago I walked out of church a
mail truck went by I thought wait a
minute it's Sunday and of course it was
chock full of Amazon packages well it's
amazing how fast customers have really
adjusted and loved the Sunday delivery
that we're getting we now have 19 sort
centers across the United States
supporting Sunday delivery to thousands
of cities that's a tremendous benefit of
being part of our our prime program in
true 7-day deliver is the job of pickers
and stores final questions a better or
worse for them working with the robots I
mean if they're if they're
productivity's gotta be so much higher
are they're working so much harder or is
it better cuz I don't have to walk ten
or twelve miles a day well I would
encourage you to talk to him I think
what you'll find is the pickers and
stores really enjoy working with the
system because what they're getting to
do now is much more of the direct piece
that customers appreciate all our
employees are owners in the company and
as owners in the company they know what
customers value in terms of selection
speeding and price and they know now
that what they're doing is all directly
rated to what customers want either
making selection available faster or
picking an order faster and I think they
the feedback has been super positive on
their job satisfaction is better because
they're getting to think more and walk
less well they're certainly going to do
deal with a new level of technology that
you need to deal with a new system and
they're getting you know their customers
are seeing the direct benefit from it